Mary here with a gamespot news update it
looks like Legend of Zelda for Wii U is
going to have a world as big as the
system hardware will allow longtime
Zelda series producer Eiji Aonuma said
in an interview with game reactor
magazine ever since we made the very
first generation of Legend of Zelda
we've had as large a world as can be
realized with the hardware so you could
say it was inevitable that we've now
done the same with the new wii u title
we've only caught a couple peaks at the
upcoming zelda and the scale definitely
seems much larger than anything we've
seen from the previous entries in the
series Shigeru Miyamoto said that the
Twilight Princess entire map would only
represent one area of the new game given
the size of the world the wii u zelda
game is frequently being referred to as
an open-world game onuma however takes
issue with that description not because
it's inaccurate but because zelda games
have always allowed you to roam and
explore a huge world the distinguishing
factor of the upcoming zelda according
to a NUMA is this time around the world
is a seamless one instead of being
segmented into several areas the new
zelda game is expected to come out
sometime this year so we'll likely have
more updates around it probably around
III so be sure to check out gamespot com
flash news for the latest